Hey wisecrack Jared here today
We're donning our trench coats as we talk about what went wrong with the final installment of the rather tragic Matrix trilogy The Matrix Revolutions
We could talk about the flat characters unclear motivations and structural cluster books
But perhaps the most important thing to address is the fact that well the movie just doesn't make much sense
Or to put it more generously it has some colossal narrative gaps
We basically can't make sense of the plot without some pretty massive
Interpretive leads here are our top three burning questions one how the hell does neo have powers outside the matrix
Two does neo make his own choices, or is he just a pawn of larger forces
And three is neo supposed to be Jesus again
And how does this religious imagery fit into the story?
Given how much thought went into these films it can't be that the witch house
He's just dropped the narrative ball so royally right so if the answers don't lie in the narrative perhaps
They lie in the philosophies that inspired the film's welcome to this wisecrack Edition on The Matrix Revolutions
What went wrong and of course spoilers ahead in case? You don't read watch the trilogy every few weeks
Here's a recap in the matrix neo wakes up from a simulated reality to discover machines control the world and he is the one
prophesized to save humans from their metal foes
Digital ass-kicking ensues in reloaded these dreams are dashed when we discover that neo is not
Special the prophecy was part of the machines scheme all along and the film ends with him gaining insane powers
but also in a coma in revolutions neo wakes from his coma and
Cooperates with the machines to beat Agent Smith in a fight to the death saving humans, and maybe machines from lives of servitude
So how does neo have power in the real world the only explanation in the film were given is this tell me how I?
Separated my mind from my body without jacking it
Tell me how I stopped four sentinels by thinking it
Tell me just what the hell is to me the power of the one extends beyond this world
It reaches from here all the way back to where it came from
where the source
That's what you felt when you touch those sentinels, and then in the ends of the matrix video game. We get this touched the source
and
Separated its mine from his body, but these are basically non
Explanations since they don't you know actually explain anything there are also fan theories
Maybe there's a matrix within a matrix or maybe Neos wirelessly connected to the source dial-up is very 90s
But none of these are really textually supported instead we think these mysterious powers have something to do with French philosopher Jean Baudrillard
In the matrix the Wachowskis reference boatyards several times welcome to the desert
The desert of the real characterizes Bois Gerard's critique of the postmodern era where meaning and reality are replaced by
Speier representations for Baudrillard the term simulacra describes signs that have no relation to the real
But pretend to like a painting that looks like a Polaroid photo of a unicorn on Instagram
When these fake copies without originals get together they form simulations and when simulations hook up
They replace reality with the virtual the web of media were plugged into all day
What's worse?
There's no easy exit from the virtual
You can't tell it isn't real because who even remembers what reality is when the virtual becomes more real than reality itself
We enter hyper reality where technologies and simulations control meaning not humans like a desert wasteland
Reality is emptied of meaning for humans the problem is the Wachowski took this a bit literally
They show technology that controls meaning by literally enslaving humans meanwhile
The real is a literal desert or more like Mordor Meets, Manhattan
And the matrix is not just simulated ideas and technologies but a physical network into which humans are
Literally plugged even Baudrillard himself criticized the which housekeys saying they took the hypothesis of the virtual for an irrefutable fact
And transformed it into a visible phantasm
But it is precisely that we can no longer employ categories of the real in order to discuss the characteristics of the virtual
That's French for they fucked up for beau Gerard
there are no red pills and blue pills or
External reference points from which you can distinguish the real
From the fake if you could one could easily choose the real as neo and others do so laying one
final bit of smack beau Gerard insisted
What would be interesting is to show what happens when these two?
Worlds collide it seems the witch house keys not only took boatyards words to heart
They plotted a pretty wild course correction in the sequels
They attempt to merge the real in the virtual by giving neo powers in the quote real world we start the trilogy thinking of neo
As real and the matrix and its programs as fake
But as the matrix revolution seems to imply we're wrong neo doesn't just plug into the virtual he can't
unplug from it the virtual is inside of him when he kills the Sentinels or
experiences the train station in a coma we see a more
complex idea of the virtual that is not the opposite of the real but a layer of the real or interwoven and
Confused with it that neo can tap into this may also explain how?
Smith entered the real world when Smith clones himself onto Bain the real becomes virtual the virtual becomes real and the distinction
between mind and body
Collapses this idea of the real world as virtual can also explain
Why Denis au can see the world as energy pulses as if it's?
Virtual here the Wachowskis borrow from the old archetype of the blind seer someone who through seeing less
Actually understands more Odin even plucked out his own eye to gain knowledge although
It's probably not what Bogart had in mind Neos blindness
Helps him literally see a fundamental truth about the relationship between the real and the virtual
Namely that they aren't as separate as he thought finally beau Jerrod helps explain
What's happening in that train station the weird limbo space between the real and the virtual?
Here neo discovers programs who want to escape the so-called real world where they're forced to carry out their programming
and it's to hide in the matrix from the perspective of humans the matrix is a
Deceptive false space that steals their agency
But for the program's the matrix is a Liberatore space where they can be their true selves if you're a digital
Entity maybe the virtual world is the real world?
This is perhaps. Why at the very end the Oracle is ambiguous in her plea to the architect. What about the others what others?
Come on. Say what out?
Obviously, they will be freed is she referring to the humans or machines could be both
but for the machines getting out might mean getting in and for the humans vice versa
This brings us to the conflict between choice and determinism
Which if you remember from our Matrix Reloaded video they never shut up about causality
Action, reaction
Cause and effect
Everything begins with choice.
No. Wrong
Inevitable is literally the last word neo ever speaks. That's right
Right after he says
But wait
Choose what to keep fighting something else be clear man, and whatever choice
He refers to is it even up to neo, or is he just the product of larger fates and factors?
How does this fit in with the Oracles apparent omniscience?
Is it some mutation in his
programming or purpose that drives
Agent Smith to start a clone war?
Is it chance or does he reveal that programs have the capacity for choice and free will?
Let's see if we can use some philosophy of freewill
Determinism and fatalism to make sense of vision show most of us experience ourselves as making choices
We write geeky videos on Friday nights because like neo we choose to and not because we don't have friends
For Aristotle. This is because humans are rational animals our reason
helps us to make choices and differentiates us from other animals and technology
To call something a choice one must be able to act otherwise and not be driven by mere
instinct or
programming and
Most of us probably agree with David Hume that the ability to act or not act
According to our own desires and reason is the basis of human freedom neo Morpheus
And the rest of the gang certainly agree
And they are cheats off because humans are being treated well like machines with their minds and bodies
totally controlled while plugged into the matrix they don't seem to have the
Capacity to act otherwise and of course the arc of the whole series bends toward gaining freedom
But of course it's not that simple neo and friends
Don't realize that freedom of choice is actually part of the matrix itself in perhaps the most
cryptic conversation in cinema history the architect reveals earlier versions of the matrix didn't work because
Even though the world was perfect for humans they were being forced choice
Choice but choice is so essential humans valued it even over perfect happiness. Did you know that the first matrix?
Was designed to be a perfect human world where none suffered where everyone would be happy
It was a disaster
No one would accept the program entire crops were lost
The current matrix only works because it accounts for the human need to choose
albeit a
paradoxical choice to give up their freedom
As I was saying she stumbled upon a solution whereby nearly 99% of all test subjects accepted the
Program as long as they were given a choice. Even if they were only aware of the choice at any unconscious level
Hey wait doesn't this look similar to?
Boatyards claim that we prefer and willingly give up control of meaning to the virtual why yes?
It does Jared anyway this produces anomalies in the heart of the system neo and his five
predecessors human choice means there are some aspects of the architects plan that can't be
Predicted and turn neo who chooses to save Trinity instead of reloading the matrix freewill one
Determinism zero, but does neo really make a choice. There are several reasons to wonder first
It looks like neo chooses to give the architects plan a big middle finger and run off to save Trinity
But for Aristotle and Aquinas the passions like love anger jealousy or the Kryptonite of choice and free will
They're no more than animal impulses
The architect also isn't buying it
Maybe it's because he doesn't understand choice
You and I may not be able to see beyond our own choices
But that man can't see past any choice
Or it's because he thinks Neos return to Trinity is just the result of another causal law: Love
Already I can see the chain reaction
the chemical precursors that signal the onset of an emotion
Designed specifically to overwhelm logic and reason
Or as a wisecrack favorite puts it
What people call love is just a chemical reaction that compels animals to breed
It's possible that neo is just responding to basic evolutionary programming what the architect refers to as a chemical reaction?
Colonel Sanders and Carnot believe that everything is mechanistic the matrix fellow programs and even humans don't have choice
But operate on physical logical and mathematical laws of causation
This version of determinism dates back to ancient philosophers like
Democritus loosest and others who might confuse for diseases who began noting the physical world was not random
But governed by strict causal laws
Determinist buzzkills that they are always claimed the appearance of choice is just part of the system once the architect notices the human
Need to at least feel like they're making choices even though. They'd be plugged in like so many light brights
No matter what he just adds choice to his determinist calculations
Then the whole function of the one is to control the narrative of choice and resistance in a way that suits the machines
They're stuck in a cycle every time you think you're escaping the system
Nope Zion rises the one appears
He meets the architect the one chooses most everyone dies the matrix reload
Die on the one weird conversation choice death reload rinse and repeat until
Neo, but even if we buy that it's love with a capital L
Not just chemicals that made him exit door number two or do whatever he's referring to here
There are still reasons to be suspicious that it was a genuine choice for medieval theologian and forty year old virgin Thomas Aquinas
Choice is not enough
It's our free will that makes us sensitive to which goals are best or most moral and allows us to be held responsible
For our choices is Neos will free well one very powerful old lady and something called fatalism makes that
unlikely and
Fatalism is like determinism with a heaping spoonful of the supernatural less focused on physical laws
Fatalist claimed events are destined to occur because the gods the fates or even our own character and compulsions
Directly cause them to and if by gods they mean a bearded math program a cookie baking prophet and a self-replicating
Lord Elrond then we're inclined to agree over the course of the films the Oracles been very busy
She's the one behind the prophecy and if we're to believe the prophecy is just a mekinese entomb ed out the anomaly
And guide him to the source
Then that would mean she's tricking neo and his pals into almost every one of their decisions even when she pretends
It's his choice
through a
Fatalist lens it almost seems like she and the architect are pulling all the strings and the whole series is just a game of chess
Between the two of them you create a very dangerous game
Then again the witch house Keys leave us wondering does the Oracle really make her own choices
Or is she just a product of fate and determinism - by Aristotle and Aquinas his definitions
It seems she does make choices. I made a choice she
Makes the choice to save sati and let agent smith turn her into a clone
But she also says she made these choices to fulfill her purpose. What's your purpose?
To unbalance it she also says they had to happen. I'm sure this had to happen
I'm sorry. I couldn't be sitting here like you remember me
But it wasn't meant to be so maybe she isn't making choices
So if neo isn't making his own choices and the Oracle might not be either then is anyone this movie is freaking impossible
Maybe agent Smith as his name suggests is the only real being with
Agency in the film when he's killed by neo. He refuses to return to the source to be destroyed
I knew the rules I understood what I was supposed
It's a choice similar to the one neo makes right know by his own accounts Smith is a die-hard fatalist
And he doesn't see this as a matter of will but part of a grander plan. We're not here because
We're here, because we are not free there is no escaping reason
No denying purpose because as we both know without purpose
We would not exist and he's pretty sure his purpose is still to kill neo
ultimately Agent Smith believes freedom truth peace and love are just illusions and
Fantasies as meaningless as the matrix itself is it freedom
perhaps peace could it be full of
Illusions, mr.. Anderson vagaries, it's perception
Temporary constructs of a feeble human intellect trying desperately to justify an existence that is without meaning or purpose
And all of them as artificial as the matrix itself only programming and fate are real and because they're not programmed
Human lives are empty, but just when determinism and fate appear to have kicked out of choice
We're reminded that we'll for freedom peace and love means something for both humans and programs
I love my daughter very much. I just have never heard a program speak of love
It is a human emotion. No it is a word
But matters is the connection the word implies. Love is not just an illusion or some chemical BS
It's a powerful and meaningful
Connection and so is freedom or the freedom to do otherwise?
Sati doesn't have a purpose I find it to be the most beautiful thing. I've ever seen
But where we are from that is not enough
Every program that is created must have a purpose if it does not it is deleted
But her life is still worth living and she should be free to live it
Neo realizes that just as humans can't exercise their free will some programs can't either
Maybe this is what makes neo realize that it isn't just humanity that needs saving from this war if we really want to talk about
Choice there must be choice for everyone then again before we can put our neck braces away
We're in for more whiplash cuz it's the Oracle who sent sati and her family here at this exact time for this
Revelation about freedom what choice?
To help you to guide meal kind of makes it again seem like she's controlling
Everything after all this and all the films chitchat about choice
It's not clear that neo or anyone else for that matter actually makes one
If nobody is making choices that is neo even the real
Protagonist is it the Oracle are we even supposed to care as that there aren't enough?
unexplained plot points revolutions ends with some confusing religious imagery
What exactly is this glowing jacked in Jesus supposed to show us maybe we can explain this in terms of choice versus fate?
but also
Faith from the beginning neo is a quasi religious figure who helps save humans from their ignorance and enslavement in the matrix
He's basically straight out of the Gnostic Gospels
Which talked about a savior who is the ultimate guide to the nature of reality?
This group of religious mostly Christian heretics in the early seee claimed that humans perceived the material world in darkness
Sleep night and blindness and must be saved through waking knowledge light etc
Sound familiar neo basically spends half the trilogy. Just waking up when neo sacrifices himself
He enables true knowledge of reality and peace between machines and humans, but it's not determinism that gets him this far
it's faith he has faith in his purpose and in the
Possibility of peace even when he doesn't have a fucking clue what he's doing. I know I'm supposed to go
but beyond that I
Don't know even the faith of the other characters play a big role in turning the tides of the war yeah
So while we can't explain how
Neo raises the dead or how the blind can see that kind of seems like part of the point
maybe the religious imagery is the last word on the whole determinism business some things exist beyond reason clarity or
Calculations, maybe part of what makes us human is this capacity for faith in peace in goodness and something beyond ourselves
So far we've tried to fill some plot holes by exploring the Wachowskis philosophy phase
But perhaps the answer to our question has been lying in a small detail all along the Oracles earrings
Maybe many of the inexplicable
Happenings and revolutions are there to prove some sort of uni and yang II point that it's not about winning
But balance the philosophy of yin, and yang found in Taoism and Confucianism is present in the film's not only in jewelry
but in themes like balance cycles and
Dichotomies according to Chinese philosopher Jo dong Yi Yin represents a dark
Condensing force and is associated with metal fire and the material world yang is associated with light
expanding forces water earth chi or energy
forces and life flows
Notice that in revolutions the real world is full of
machines and bodies and is literally dark and on fire while the virtual world is of the mind where things are light and
Well not on fire, but yin, and yang are not dichotomies
They stand for opposite
But connected forces like a light and dark side of the same hill so why do Asian Smith and neo both have
Unexplained powers and obsess over each other because they are yin and yang light and dark sides of the same anomaly what is he?
He is you
your opposite negative to be showed at the
Equation trying to balance it's how about instead of confusing the real and the virtual a la Baudrillard yin
And yang help explain how the real and the virtual are two sides of the same coin
And both are important for achieving peace between machines and humans was neo making his own choices
Or was he determined by larger fates like the architect and the Oracle who are also a bit Union Yankee
We'll never really know but in revolutions choice and fate are a bit yin
And yang equally important aspects of the human experience is the matrix really a religious allegory
Bringing credence to the prophecy or did the Oracle make the whole thing up to win a game of wits against the architect again?
We'll never know
but maybe that's deliberate both faith and faith are important aspects of making meaning for programs and
Humans and maybe we're being too meta here
But it seems revolutions even combines eastern and western
Philosophy has two important parts of the philosophical story so to summarize what went wrong well
We've spent over 20 minutes philosophizing about these films and still have no idea
What exactly happened, but maybe that's the point the film seems committed to being beyond sense?
If they told us everything or flawlessly implemented each
Philosophy wouldn't they just undermine their whole point that some things are beyond reasoning calculation
And that's okay or maybe we're giving the Wachowskis too much credit either way despite their flaws
We won't be unplugging from these stories anytime soon
Thanks for watching wisecrack
We love making videos for y'all
And it's your support that keeps us going so another way to support us is by becoming a patron
patrons get immediate access to exclusive
patron only releases including special
Podcasts our new video on the movie it and a sneak peek of our upcoming wisecrack edition on the philosophy of mr.
Robot and another new thing we're trying out is a podcast format called wisecrack edition
Extra you guys are always asking us about behind the scenes stuff like what does the research process look like what is the writing process?
Look like what does it take to make these videos? Well now. I'm holding hour-long
conversations with the writers
researchers and directors of these videos to help you give you guys extra content if you want to think more about these properties so if
You guys are matrix philosophy freaks. I just recorded an exclusive interview with the writer and researcher of this video. You're watching right now
You'll get access to the podcast and everything else on our patreon page plus
We're working on more exclusives each month once we reach our big milestone
We'll be able to branch out even further
Look there are tons of movies and TV shows out there that we'd love to cover
But the reality of running a YouTube channel is that you have to focus on stuff
That's super popular in order to keep the lights on so by helping us reach our next milestone
We'll be able to make deeper track videos on topics you guys request all the time stuff like whiplash Drive
Twin Peaks Fargo and tons more and as a patron you'll get exclusive access to these videos
months before anyone else so click here or use the link in the description to visit our patreon page and become a patron and if
You're hungry for more matrix content before you go check out our matrix playlist here. Thanks again for the love y'all peace
You